[Musique]
les liens qui unissent cette jeune
famille font éclater des conventions on
croyait immuables rdée mode accompagne
son frère mathias et benoît le conjoint
de celui ci qui sont les deux papas
légalement il n'y a pas de maire rené
mode et la tente mais d'une façon toute
spéciale
quant au bébé il y en a deux mois c'est
benoît hellings et moi c'est mathias et
ses vaches elles benoît et mattia sont
en couple depuis huit ans les jeunes
pharmaciens se sont connus pendant leurs
études universitaires
moi j'ai toujours voulu avoir des
enfants mais je savais pas comment j'en
aurais je pense je sais pas si c'était
possible à cause du chili on s'est
présentés benoît ma famille nous avait
20 ans puis
qui a le dit spontanément 6ème année
vous voulez que je vous donne des ovules
sa dalle dit quelque chose de spontané
comme ceux à le dit garder la tête puis
on en reparlera de mon frère c'est
toujours été mon meilleur ami le matin
il se réveille faisais mon lit je suis
peut-être aujourd'hui tu vas mettre ses
pantalons l'eau avec ton chandail j'ai
fait ondines et ont déjeuné dans mon
frère était comme mon rôle si je pouvais
réaliser leur rêve de mon frère et de
son conjoint d'avoir des enfants
le rêve d'une vie j'allais j'allais le
faire sans poser de questions sans
savoir dans quoi je m'embarquais en fait
rumeau de la petite soeur de matthias
entreprend donc le processus de
prélèvement de ciseaux vul en septembre
j'ai parlé et d'huile j'avoue les
injections deux à trois fois par jour
des présents chaque jour des injections
intra vaginale 6 et des produits
chimiques on injecte sont obligés de
dire les effets secondaires
bon tu vas prendre du poids environ 20,5
en crise tout va vomir après cette
première expérience éprouvante
l'implantation des embryons est un échec
rené mot doit tout recommencer pendant
ce temps benoît et mathias cherche une
mère porteuse
ils ont un obstacle important franchir
c'est légalement c'est impossible au
québec une entente de gestation pour
autrui serait déclarée nulle par les
tribunaux il leur faut regarder ailleurs
au pays
le recrutement de la mère porteuse se
passe en ontario où il y à quelques
agences
on en trouve aussi en colombie
britannique les candidats doivent avoir
au moins un enfant être en excellente
santé physique et mentale et vivre une
relation stable
on a augmenté un portfolio danser mais
il faut tout nous notre histoire
pourquoi qu'on voulait des enfants d'où
on vient
c'est quoi notre projet de famille puis
ensuite c'est pour nous qui choisissons
la porteuse c'est la porteuse qui
choisit le couple pour lequel elle veut
porter après un an d'attenté
une mère de famille de 32 ans que nous
appellerons leslie se manifeste sa
propre soeur a été porteuse à trois
occasions transparence car on décide que
on s'entend bien qu'on le fasse ensemble
on avise lagence plus le processus
commence par un site
c'était lé maître chéri levitan que
benoît et mathias embauche une des
grandes spécialistes basés à toronto
elle a déjà réalisé plus de 1000 contrat
de gestation pour autrui
ensemble avec l'esl et ils tentent de
prévoir toutes les éventualités entre
autres ça veut dire si un trisomique est
ce qu'on fait il faut que nous et c'est
que pour 12 enfants soient d'accord
d'une malformation milan ça ne dérange
pas mais une malformation deux majeurs
ont préféré terminer la grossesse s'il y
avait une décision à prendre quant au
bien-être de l'enfant c'était nous qui
ces sociétés qui étaient considérés
comme étant les parents avec le sperme
de benoît la clinique de fertilité
produit des embryons
puis les implants avec succès la
grossesse de leslie se déroule bien mais
après quatre mois une grosse surprise
des attentats ont été commis par un on
parle avec elle sur skype
elle montera photos qu'on voit très bien
que ces deux ambiant mon palm a pleuré
on est heureux extraire ou 2016 le
couple se rend à landon accompagné
leslie dans sa dernière semaine de
grossesse l'accouchement se déroule bien
et les petites naissent à la date prévue
y at il quelqu'un qui a coupé le cordon
comment ça s'est passé dans nos voitures
que j'ai quasiment oublie la moitié des
choses se passent mal à convaincre le
président à vous deux l'amour entre les
frères et ça c'est super fort et c'est
super important
j'espère que vous allez vous aimez vous
tant que papa mathias et ils m'attendent
poule c'est que vous allez vous soutenir
dans les moments difficiles comme dans
les moments de battre prenez soin l'une
de l'autre cinéma tente poule
[Musique]
devenir papa leur a coûté près de 85
mille dollars comme la commercialisation
des fonctions reproductives est illégale
au canada
seules les dépenses reliées à la
grossesse ont pu être remboursé à la
mère porteuse
ainsi les cela a reçu 22 mille dollars
ailleurs comme en californie la
maternité de substitution pu rapporter
jusqu'à 50000 $ en plus des dépenses
benoît et matthias ont déboursé près de
30000 dollars en clinique de fertilité
dix mille dollars pour les frais légaux
et 7000 $ pour l' agence pour mieux
s'occuper des jumelles les deux papas en
profiter chacun de leur congé parental
puis ils sont retournés habitants à leur
travail de faire un ancien excellent
avec deux bébés d'un mois la star
prétend le couple veut qu'ils lisent et
rachel connaissent leur histoire ils
leur ont préparé cet album qui relate
les grands moments et qui expliquent
pourquoi elles n'ont pas de maman
qu'est-ce que je peux faire que maffre
et robin farci de voir le consoler denis
la tendresse des fous tout faire ce la
veut devenir mannequin sinon mais on a
tellement tu rentres dans notre vie je
sa soeur ma marque efficacement toutes
les semaines on a peine à me fit donc il
voir tellement de femmes tellement de
modèles de femmes que ça c'est un
problème non plus
j'ai juste envie d'être une tente
spéciale une tante aimante qui utilise
un plus et puis qui les aime plus que
tout on va ce disque est d'une façon
aucun enfin compris que ma tante poule a
donné 10 pour nous aider à avoir des
enfants piqué et nos femmes qui nous a
et dire en les couvrant pendant neuf
mois qu'on va laisser à nos enfants de
façon claire van rompuy on veut pas leur
mentir on veut qu'ils comptent qui
comprennent vraiment tous les papas ont
aussi gardé un lien étroit avec leslie
ils veulent que les jumelles la
connaissent
[Musique]
la famille de matthias arrive de
gatineau les trois grands parents et ses
parents stéphane et julie a plus de
monde qu'on peut sait comment ça s'est
passé puis on est on est fier de lui et
pas n'importe quelle femme je pense que
pourrait porter des des enfants les
satyres en daim puis d'être capable de
se séparer du lien physique ça doit pas
être pressé le tapage doigt les lits les
plus de deuils de savoir que tu étais
guy peut-être à cause de petites et
peut-être y avait pas d'enfants dans la
famille parce que c'est comme si à mais
finalement même si guy y avoir des
enfants c'est pas si grave
je pense je pense que c'est comme ça non
non elise police les jumelles porteront
les noms de famille de leurs deux papas
duprat gonthier ont tous les deux
qu'elle nous appelle papa est bon est ce
que ça va être papa ben papa titi titi
pour massage ou bien que ça va être papa
pas en ce moment à chelles a commencé a
dit d'adp web d'ethernet dada j'accepte
le dada de prendre le peuple
[Musique]